shortly but firstly i just want to get
your reaction on what grant sharps just
said to us there do you believe that the
boss of pianos should go right now
yes i do
agree with grant schapps i mean what has
happened
um is an outrage uh happening at a
incredibly tough time
uh for people with rising inflation
um anyway
but i have to say i also think that the
government changing
the law around fire and rehire was
unacceptable in the first place and i
think it set up the circumstances
in which
uh ordinary hard-working people could be
treated um in this way we will
scrutinize the legislation that he says
he's coming forward with but frankly it
shouldn't have taken this in the first
place
and grant sharp said when i spoke to him
earlier was calling for cross-party
support to get the process through
parliament um quicker will labour
support that
let's look at the bill that he says that
he's bringing forward i don't think
we've seen the detail uh we'll
scrutinize it um and of course we'll
support uh where we can but i would be
surprised if we aren't asking quite
searching questions um uh
as a result of this in the first place
in terms of when mr schapps was aware of
the situation in ukraine we're getting
some conflicting news
the boss yesterday in front of mps said
actually mr schatz was made aware of
this in november he has denied that um
but if we do get information later on
that says the opposite that actually any
revelations come out that says actually
mr shaps did indeed know about this um
in november as um as was said to mps
yesterday do you think that will make
his role untenable
yes
because he would have lied
and we have to live in a country where
we expect
um ministers
uh in the event that they're found not
to be telling the truth to resign and to
go
um so i hope that is not the situation
for grant schnapps but if he's in that
situation i'm afraid
uh he would have to go
and can you spell out for us what labour
would do then to close the loopholes
which allowed 800 people to be sacked on
the spot via video
labour's been campaigning for a very
very long time and this came up during
the pandemic when we had other major
employees uh sack people summarily um
and then re-hire people
at significantly lower rates we've been
campaigning supported uh by many of the
unions on fire and rehire
and we would absolutely outlaw that
practice that's been absolutely crystal
clear now um for many many months indeed
let's move on now to matters concerning
um ukraine and
what's labour's position on tanks and
planes being given to the country
look i think that it was absolutely
right yesterday for jan staltenberg for
joe biden and for others to set out very
very clearly that we would continue to
support
ukraine with lethal weapons um to deal
with the assault um that they are now
facing um i think that it's the
assessment of nato allies and i'm here
in germany uh speaking to the germans
about this it's the assessment across
nato that actually it's anti-tank
missiles and it's anti-air weaponry
that's hugely important there are huge
logistics involved with supplying tanks
and supplying aircraft
that the ukrainians themselves are
equipped to use at this stage given that
um vladimir putin has not got control of
the skies across ukraine it's the
ability to take down
um
aircraft where they are seen and
absolutely to deal with
tanks that's required and that missile
equipment has come from the united
kingdom and it's come of course from the
united states
should we commit to the one percent of
nato firepower that uh president
zielinski has asked for
well look i think that um
broadly president
has been pleased with the response that
he's got from the uk there are different
capabilities across the 30 nato
countries all of them assessing what
more they can do
at this time
i think it's hugely important to
remember that vladimir putin has not met
his military objectives he thought
effectively that this war would be over
by now and what he's meant is dogged
resistance and ukrainians equipped to
deal with the threat that they are
facing
we have now got to gird ourselves um for
more of this over many weeks and sadly
many months and of course you've heard
um the real concerns about the use of
chemical weapons um and the scenario
planning that nato allies are doing
if that eventuality were to come to pass
and very shortly we're waiting to hear
from president joe biden who will be
speaking alongside ursula van der lion
um is ukraine right when it says that
the west acted too slow when it came to
sanctions
well
the labour party had been pushing the uk
government uh on sanctions at every
single stage and there is more to do
uh more oligarchs to name more to do in
dealing with family members more to do
with addressing issues that companies
house
more to do with more sectors of the
economy continuing uh to see
much more banks
cut out effectively this is russian
banks of the international system so yes
labour would say that there is more to
do on sanctions and that we have moved
um too slowly but of course we recognize
that there were more uh commitments made
by the government in the last few days
and that we are seeing for example the
ruble falling um currency uh problems
now in russia reserves being cut and
that is as a result of the united action
across eu
and including the uk